welcome to the special report homepage
I'm Bret Baier we had a good discussion
on the panel tonight about Russia and
Great Britain in a high-level stare down
over the poisoning of a double agent you
can see the segment right here on the
website along with report by Amy Kellogg
also on the homepage John Roberts on
rumblings about more personnel shakeups
at the White House and my interview with
Democratic National Committee Chairman
Tom Perez plus Phil Keating on school
walkouts over gun violence Thursday I'll
talk with Senate Judiciary Committee
Chairman Chuck Grassley and committee
member Lindsey Graham they have some
interesting news
we'll see it at 6:00 p.m. Eastern on Fox
News Channel four special report